well it looks like we might finally be
getting to the end of the the Cavanaugh
saga the FBI report is done will we ever
see it seems not but but we do know that
Democrats and Christine Ford's attorneys
have already complained that it was it's
it's unfair the investigation was unfair
yadda yadda yadda they're saying that
it's not a legitimate and this is a huge
shock by the way no one saw this coming
I mean we all thought that they would
certainly accept the results right
that's what we all thought what one
complain I think a really stupid
complaint is well the FBI didn't
interview Christine Ford or Brett
Kavanaugh
well they we've already heard from them
they've given their side of the story in
lengthy interviews in front of the
Senate so all the FBI would do is just
ask them the same exact questions again
which actually I you know Ford's
attorneys should be happy that that that
she wasn't interviewed because she's the
one with the constantly changing story
so she may not hold up well under FBI
interrogation but they did interview all
the alleged witnesses and everything so
that there's no point in them in them
hearing yet again the same story from
Cavanaugh and Ford instead okay they're
gonna go and listen to the alleged
witnesses let's get their stories but
they don't like that so I so I think we
could ascertain from that that the
investigation didn't uncover anything
and didn't corroborate Ford's accounts
in fact if it uncovered anything it just
further uncovered the fact that
Christine Ford is lying and I just want
to underscore that point quickly I wrote
about this yesterday and you know I was
among those in the early going who I
wanted to be gentle with Christine Ford
and I wanted to be generous to her give
her the benefit of the doubt as much as
possible and that doesn't mean taking
her story at face value because
I never did that you know smart person
you never should have done that because
there were always holes in the story and
so on and so forth
but I thought okay maybe and I said this
multiple times you know I I said maybe
she was maybe she's mistaken maybe she's
missed remembering even as the
inconsistencies piled up I said like
many supporters of Brett Kavanaugh and
like Brett Kavanaugh himself I mean he
said this himself on multiple occasions
that maybe something bad did happen to
her and she's just conflating she's
she's misconstruing accidentally
conflating one thing with another
injecting Brett Kavanaugh into it
accidentally maybe that's that's what I
thought that's that's what I mean by
giving her the benefit of the doubt but
I think now now that we've seen all this
play out and we've seen the evidence or
lack thereof or really we've seen the
evidence which all comes down in
Cavanaugh's favor I think we have to
stop being so gentle about it and say
what is now very difficult to avoid but
what I think is a plain reality which is
that Christine Ford is a liar she may
still have been victimized at some point
in some form at some point in her life
and and if if that's the case then I
feel badly for her for that abuse if she
ever did suffer it at some point but
it's just not possible anymore for
someone for a rational person to say to
theorize that this may all be a case of
mistaken identity
somebody somebody is a liar here
somebody is they straight-up liar and to
me it seems very clear that that person
is christine ford and that's there's a
reason why Rachel Mitchell who's the sex
crimes prosecutor hired by the
Republicans there's a reason why she
wrote that lengthy memo we talked about
few days ago where she said she didn't
find the story credible at all there are
too many gaps and not just gaps but the
gaps are far too convenient that she
can't remember specific she specifically
can't remember any of the details that
may
exonerates ford or or may confirm any of
the details that could confirm or
disprove her claim she can't remember
any of those conveniently she also can't
remember the things that she did and
said even a few months ago so here's the
thing if her memory is really that
terrible that you can't remember
anything even even things that happened
in the last month or two well in that
case if her memory is that bad I have a
bad memory okay I know that I have a bad
memory that's one thing I remember is
having a bad memory if her memory is
really bad and it seems like her memory
would be worse than mine if this really
isn't a memory issue then she knows that
her memory is bad which means she knows
that she cannot speak with absolute
certainty about something that happened
35 years ago so even in that case even
if most of this is a memory issue we
still have she said it was she's a
hundred percent sure it was Cavanaugh
but if her memory is that bad then she
knows that she can't possibly be 100%
sure so at a minimum that's a lie and
it's a big one
but but it's more than that Ford story
has changed over and over again and it's
changed in a way that's not that is that
is not just haphazard it's changed in
ways that seem calculated and targeted
to kind of get around Cavanaugh's
defenses so if we're going to absolve
her of all dishonesty at this point then
we have to believe that her memory
lapses are couldn't coincidentally
convenient and the gaps in her story are
coincidentally convenient and the
changes in her story are coincidentally
convenient and not only that but it's
also coincidentally convenient that all
of the the witnesses that she claims
have also suffered amnesia around the
same kinds of events then there's Ford's
ex-boyfriend who came out issued a sworn
statement claiming that a Ford coached
her friend on how to pass a lie-detector
test claimed that Ford flew
recreationally all the
which would seem to dispel the notion
that she has the sphere flying Ford
never once mentioned any sexual assault
despite having dated him for years now
on on the lie-detector thing the the
friend that Ford supposedly coached did
come out the next day and denied denied
it but notice something first of all she
denied it to the press she didn't deny
it under oath second and I'm not saying
it's true but she has to deny it
because if she admitted that she was
coached on how to pass a lie-detector
test when going for this whatever
government job she would lose her job
and she could even go to jail so she
can't she has note if it happened she
has no choice but to deny it I would
ruin her career ruin everything
but the real significance I think of her
boyfriends testimony is that it is just
another person who denies or refutes
elements of Ford's story so if Ford
isn't lying it means that her
ex-boyfriend is lying it means that
Cavanaugh is lying it means Marc judge
is lying it means two other witnesses as
well are either suffering selective
amnesia or are lying so it's five
against one
okay and that one five against one and
the one is a very very lonely one your
one is a lonely number especially for
Ford because think about what it's only
one and that means that not even her
parents or other family members or other
friends nobody has come forward to vouch
for any aspect of her story at all and
in fact I think the silence of the
people around her is so deafening and so
noticeable and so peculiar that it
almost counts as yet another witness
against her so she's lying where did the
lie originate where did it begin why did
it begin you know why would she lie
about that I that's a question we hear a
lot is well why why would somebody lie
about
thing like this well I don't know we can
only speculate and it's actually it's
not that hard to speculate it's not that
hard to believe that somebody could lie
about something like this number one
because we know people lie about this
kind of stuff and we can go through all
the examples Duke Lacrosse rolling stone
Lena Dunham all that stuff we could go
through all the examples of false rape
accusations but but but even before that
we we know why people lie right because
we've all told lies so you know why
people lie
now hopefully you haven't told any lies
as big as as this or as damaging as this
but you still told lies and I think that
small lies and big lies generally have
the same kinds of motivations behind
them so people lie why do people lie why
do you lie why have you told lies
well you've lied to gain some sort of
advantage you've lied to get attention
you've lied to maybe hurt other people
that you dislike again hopefully not to
this degree but still to some degree or
another and then sometimes people lie
inexplicably they there are times when
people lie for no reason that you can
even ascertain and then it and then it
snowballs from there so I think any or
all of these could explain Christine 4d
you you really can't know I mean I could
if we're left to speculate and she's the
one who's left us to speculate by
throwing us out there with all the
inconsistencies not even naughty there
are some things she could offer us to
give a little bit of evidence like her
therapist notes well she doesn't want to
give us those so she's left us to
speculate if I had to guess or come up
with some theory I could I don't know
but I could see maybe hypothetically a
situation where where she originally
brought this up in couples therapy
there's there's some oddness with a
couples therapy store because she said
that that she was in couples therapy
because of a remodel of the home and
specifically because she wanted a sec
front door which has to do with her fear
from the sexual assault yet apparently
the she was in couples therapy in 2012
the remodel of the hoenn was in 2008 so
four years later she's going to really I
mean four years later you're still your
your your relationship is still
suffering from the remodel and you have
to go I don't know what's the connection
between another front door and sexual
assault well apparently they were they
were hosting interns I think from Google
or something and so they had interns and
young men in the house that they were
having in the house and so she wanted
another front door so that they weren't
traipsing through the house because she
was afraid of the interns sexually
assaulting her and so she wanted you to
get them out of the front door that's
the story she tells well that's kind of
weird though right because if you really
are that paralyzed with fear that one of
these guys might sexually assault you
why are you hosting them in your home in
the first place it seems like that's it
seems like the argument would be if
you're if your husband wanted to have
the interns the argument would be no I
don't want them not let's get a second
front door but anyway you could if you
we needed to speculate you could see a
situation maybe where this where she
started to kind of spin the story in
couples counseling for one reason or
another and it snowballed from there we
can't see the therapist notes I think
the reason why we can't see the
therapist notes is that the story is
significantly different the story she
told her therapist is significantly
different from the story she's telling
us now including we're told she didn't
tell the therapist the name of the
person I think she may very well have
said to the therapist I don't remember
who it was something like that so she
could have started spinning the yarn
then and and it kind of just snowballed
from there so there are all kinds of of
situations but that that that doesn't
matter the Y doesn't matter it's the
what that man
and it also matters that Democrats know
that Ford's story is not credible
whatever they say they know that it's
not credible they know it swells you and
I do yet they played this hand anyway
and and I think ultimately it backfires
on them because here's what's happened
this Democrats have overplayed their
hands their hand significantly here they
have unmasked themselves at the worst
possible time because think about they
there they were headed into the midterms
they were looking pretty good they were
sitting in a pretty spot because
obviously their base hates Trump hates
Republicans so they were counting on a
good turnout meanwhile conservatives and
and Republicans have been fighting with
we've all been fighting with each other
for several years now many many good
service Republicans are feeling kind of
drained of energy somewhat despondent
right fighting amongst ourselves
bickering drained the spine that we all
these things that's not a good recipe
for voter turnouts a great recipe for
Democrats not a good recipe for
Republicans but then Democrats come
along at the last minute here they take
off the masks they reveal their fangs
and they pounce like wild animals on an
innocent man and his family and I think
that's cause most conservatives to look
at that and and and and to rally
together unite again in many ways and to
and to refocus on the real opponent and
there are polls and surveys that bear
this out but I don't even need the polls
and surveys I this is just a sense I
think if you're a public conservative or
republican you probably have sent this
census as well there's just this sense
now of a more cohesive unity among
conservatives then there's been in a
long time and that's we have the
Democrats to thank for that because I
think a lot of people have looked at
this and said wow I mean these people
are evil we got to do whatever we can to
keep them out of power that they would
stoop this low I mean sometimes it's
easy to lose sight of that sometimes to
lose sight of just how evil the
Democrats are how dishonest but they
have helpfully
I ended us of the fact and given us such
a startling illustration of it right now
right right before the midterms so I
don't know what's gonna happen in the
midterms but I think this was a terrible
strategy on their part they just don't
know when to stop they could have they
could have thrown out these
unsubstantiated allegations and just
throw them out there and then they could
rally their base a little bit around
that and kind of exploit the me2
movement even more than they already
have and rely kind of rely on that to
gin up more interest among their among
their voters and and kind of left it
there but the way that they have not let
go and even now they won't let go it's
it's backfired big time so we'll see
what happens but I'm sensing a certain
unity again that I haven't seen in a
very long time which you might say is a
little bit of the silver lining but I
hesitate to speak of silver linings when
you consider what's happened to
Cavanaugh and his family so there's
nothing that will make that worth it all
right thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed